[Music]
we are in a co-working space called
Network Hub this over here is the
reception
[Music]
the kitchen which is also a coffee shop
the hot desks which you can rent out and
over here
we have our beautiful meeting rooms it
will be pretty much impossible for us to
have access to all of these amenities as
a small business so co-working is a
really good option for us all right so
now I'll take you over to the other side
that's where our desks are
so this is us we have these two walls
over here and in the last couple of
weeks we've been building out the space
into a space that works for us it's
still a work in progress but it did
really get us to start thinking about
how we want to work and how we want to
grow as a business so in this video
obviously I'm going to show you the
space but I also want to share a little
bit about what we're trying to build and
what this business is
foreign
guys are probably a little bit surprised
right now because I haven't really
talked about this before I left my job
last month
and it was a really tough decision
um it took me about five months to
actually come to this conclusion and it
was a lot of going back and forth back
and forth and back and forth
agonizing but over the last couple of
years I realized that yes I do love
doing architecture but I also love
making videos and I also love doing
research and I love talking about
architecture and I started to feel
pretty Limited in the things that I
could do as an employee at the firm and
deep down I knew I wanted to start my
own business where I could do all of
these things and I also wanted to expand
my YouTube channel just so we're clear
without YouTube none of this would be
possible so I owe everything to you guys
and so there's the YouTube side of the
business which is the majority of the
income right now but the YouTube has
been an incredible funnel for clients
and one out of 30 of them would actually
be legit exciting projects so the
biggest thing that was holding me back
it wasn't necessarily Financial but it
had more to do with my identity I
realized that so much of my a sense of
self-worth was coming from this idea of
being an architect who worked at this
fancy firm working on these cool
projects and I'm also very conscious of
the fact that a part of the success of
this channel is because people associate
me with that
and so if I'm not doing that then what
am I take this
so when we first moved in here our space
was very much like a blank slate like we
had the space over here these two desks
and this area over here and because we
knew that we were going to be spending a
lot of time here we really wanted to
make the space work for us it helped a
lot that the owner was super flexible
with what we could do here but
essentially we wanted the space to feel
like ours while sharing it with other
people so we have three desks one for me
one for our assistant to add one for
Wrath
Raph is an experienced filmmaker and
he's going to be handling the video
production side of things RAF started
working on this full-time at the
beginning of 2022 and since then you've
probably seen the production quality go
up quite a bit one of our main
priorities was having a really large
work surface for each of us we use it
for filming and product shots and for
making models and I also want to be able
to lay out arcd drawings and scroll out
when I'm doing research and for some
reason I'm always finding that I'm
needing more space on my desk and
initially we thought about getting five
foot desks with a one foot Shelf at the
end for each of us and a larger desk for
the laser cutter but after laying out
all of the functions we still wanted a
larger surface so we decided to go with
these six foot Mega desks from ergon
office we were trying to work with the
existing color scheme in the space so
over here we got the sway desks with
this beautiful cherry wood locally
sourced and crafted in Montreal and over
here just because we knew that we were
going to be expanding so much spatially
we wanted the space to be a little bit
more muted using color
and so we ended up getting the six foot
shift desk which are super smooth in
deep black and we also got these black
pegboards we spray painted everything
black so that it kind of camouflages
into this charcoal wall these desks look
amazing in our space they're super quiet
they're heat fingerprint and scratch
resistant and they were super easy to
install it actually took us less than
half an hour but the problem with having
such a large desk surface is that we
didn't have any space for shelves
without encroaching into other people's
areas which we kind of already were
so there's a little bit of a hierarchy
to these books so everything that's on
the top shelf are the most important
books to me right now for example this
book I was referencing when I was making
the mega cities video I've been looking
at Thomas work for the house that I'm
designing in California and when I slide
it in underneath my desk then I can have
this top shelf constantly with an Arm's
Reach which is super handy because I'm
referencing these books almost on a
daily basis and I also really like how
it creates like a little enclosure for
my area I put the shelves on casters so
they can move around you can connect
them and you can arrange them in
different configurations
this is the icket show from Ikea they
come in two depths 9 inch and 12 inch
and to sit under the desk I got the nine
inch ones and stacked them in this all
configuration just so that I can slide
it underneath without taking up too much
leg room these nine inch shelves can get
a little bit limiting
especially for like monographs like this
you can see how it like sticks out a
little bit but ninety percent of my
books fit in the shelf so it was a good
compromise
they didn't have any that match the
color of the desktop so we ended up
painting the top shelves to make it look
like a part of the desktop and because
these shelves are supposed to be wall
hung and had a really ugly back we cut
spray painted and glued some cardstock
to the back and the bottom shelves I
kept it the original just so that it
gets a pop of color so when you stack
them in two the top of the Shelf comes
right up to the top of my desktop
which I have on my preset one
and if I want to slide it under I have
it on presets too
and if I want to stand I have it on
preset three
I try to stand as much as possible and
sometimes I like to sit
like
this
and that's preset four these ship desks
go from 24.5 inches to 50.2 so it's got
a really good range we align these
pegboards to sit just above rafts
standing presets so these controllers
were originally screwed onto this side
of the desk but because I wanted it to
be a little bit more flexible I just put
some Velcro on it so that I can put it
here or I can even make it disappear for
small items if they're personal items we
keep them in this drawer and for pretty
much everything else we're planning on
keeping on these pegboards because I
don't ever want to have another
conversation like this hey do you know
where the paper clips are oh my God
where did I put the exacto knife where
the [ __ ] is my tape measure we have this
electrical switch right here so after a
couple of options we landed on this
layout we've only installed it a couple
of weeks ago so there's not a lot on it
but compared to before I feel like it
adds a texture and creates a grid that
makes it feel more intentional
[Music]
when we start a video we actually spend
about two to three hours just
brainstorming for ideas and we actually
started doing this fairly recently we
started it with the Sci-Fi video and
then with the Burning Man video and then
with the mega cities video so when I
started the YouTube channel I was doing
the whole process by myself like the
ideating the scripting the research the
editing in the beginning that was fine
because I was just doing the talking in
front of the camera videos but as soon
as I wanted to improve the production
quality it became very unsustainable and
so when RAF came on board it took a huge
load off my shoulders but that actually
led to a bit of a separation in the
process for example I would finish a
script and Raph would start editing it
but we would find that a lot of the
things in the research didn't really
work visually and so we would have to
scrap the research and start over and so
it became very inefficient and so a
couple of months ago RAF had this really
great idea to talk about architecture
and Sci-Fi movies so for that we decided
to switch up the process and start
collaborating right from the start so
you have five ideas Newport City from
Ghost in the shop no Neo Tokyo tree no
night City oh
Blade Runner 2049 no
seed meat the neo-futurist concept
artist
[Music]
here is our filming station and our
model making station
this is our M1 laser cutter from X tool
and I have used many laser cutters in my
life and this one is by far the simplest
and the most intuitive let me just try
putting in a model right here
we also plan on using this like a hot
desk so if we have an architect or an
editor coming to help us out they can
sit here which is perfect because the
suede desk is super customizable you can
have up to four users and each person
can have their own settings with
pre-loaded height and once we have a
full-time local person working with us
[Applause]
this beautiful solid wood desk will be
yours
you will also get this luxury chair
which is the leather version of the
YouTube chair from urban office which
comes in all types of finishes and
colors they're super comfortable and
they can adjust to any of your ergonomic
needs so we did originally think about
placing the laser cutter on one of the
desks because we do have a fairly large
work surface because these urban office
desks are really sturdy this shift desk
can hold up to 300 pounds and the sway
desk can hold up to 360 pounds so this
laser cutter which is only 20 pounds
would have been no problem but it just
felt like a massive waste of desk space
we decided to put these on the Epic
units these are the deeper 12 inch units
attached back to back in the most
barbaric way with velcro we can store
materials underneath and on the back
side we can store leftover materials or
things that we rarely use
when you're working at a firm you will
start to get to a point in your career
where your growth starts to slow down
so
in the first few years of your time at
the firm your growth is super fast
but as you keep going it starts to slow
down but that's also when your
contribution to the firm starts to
increase
and you become more valuable to the firm
you'll probably start to make a little
bit more money because you can actually
spend your time executing the tasks to
make the machine run at this point in
terms of growth you're actually giving
more than you're gaining so when I
realized I had a really unique Niche
mixing architecture and film I saw
really good business opportunity and
because I had a very specific goal in
mind
I kind of realized that there weren't
really any way for me to gain those
skills working at The Firm I feel like
there's this mentality in architecture
that you have to work under someone that
you have to intern under someone for
like years and years and years to become
a good architect but I have come to
believe that once you have the
fundamental skills it's a matter of
gathering knowledge and there's a much
faster way for you to gather knowledge
than spending eight hours a day at the
office Magic you're trying to absorb
that information and you can do that
either through focused learning you know
taking classes or reading or reaching
out to your network and this isn't just
for architecture this is with other
disciplines as well so now I'm here
or maybe here
with the YouTube the business the
architecture and it's painful and it's
daunting but I wake up every single
morning excited to go to work
and I think for the first time in my
life I'm a hundred percent aligned in
what I want to do and what I'm doing so
I think this business is
multi-disciplinary
part YouTube part video production part
architecture part design and part
communication there's not a lot of
models to go off of but I do know that
they all have a very symbiotic
relationship I love that word on the
YouTube side we really want to increase
the production quality of every single
one of our videos and we also want to
experiment with documentary style videos
in the architecture side I'm probably
not going to work on massive projects as
of now but I'm still really excited to
start doing projects under my own name
and it's not just that in the last
couple of years I've had the chance to
work with a lot of companies that are
developing really cutting-edge
technology in architecture that I
believe is going to move the industry
forward but I've never really had the
chance to use it on a project because
most architecture practices don't really
adopt new tools because it's a huge
learning curve and it's a huge expense
even though they can improve performance
and the process so I'm super excited to
start implementing some of these tools
on my project we're actually looking for
a local editor and an architect so if
you're interested I'll leave the link in
the description if you have any
questions around any of this let me know
in the comments I know that starting
your own business can be really daunting
for example I had no idea how much all
of this background stuff was going to
cost like getting your liability
insurance and your certificate of
practice and so I will try to be as
transparent with that stuff as possible
if you want to stay up to date with what
I'm doing I have a newsletter where I
share things that I sometimes prefer not
to share in a YouTube video so I'll
leave the link to that and I also have a
Discord server where you can ask
questions to each other I'll leave the
link to that in the description as well
and with that I'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
foreign
[Music]